if you make more money sooner you will
attract more attractive women that being
said they may be more attractive
physically but then if they came to you
because you have money then why do you
think they're there and so it really
just depends on what kind of
relationship you want to have there's a
reason that they have the stories of the
popper and the prince the guy pretends
like he doesn't have money to find a
girl who actually likes him because it's
great for Instagram to have the model
next to you or whatever it is so that
you can gain status from that but like
when you're alone at night and the
person that's in bed with you you like
have no shared reality and everything
that they believe about the world you
hate is it worth it for me it's not